how many trees are there in a forest
what about a country how about in the
whole world the answer we now know is
that our planet is home to three point
zero four trillion trees that's actually
almost 8 times more than we thought as
previous estimates were only based on
satellite pictures but now we have data
not just on how much land is covered in
forest but how dense those forests are
as well measurements were collected by
thousands of people out counting trees
in forests all over the world the
average density of trees at each
location is represented by the height of
the green lines some of the densest
areas of these subarctic forests where
you can find a tree every square meter
but almost half of all our trees are
found growing in the vast tropical and
subtropical forests all this data is
going to help our understanding of where
endangered species might be able to live
how water is cycled in an ecosystem or
how much carbon dioxide is being
absorbed from the atmosphere it also
helps us work out what we ought to be
doing to preserve and replenish our
planet's forests because even accounting
for new growth we're currently losing
about 10 million trees a year at the
moment there are about 400 trees for
every person on earth but they're
disappearing at a rate of one point four
trees per person every single year if we
keep going at this rate a walk in the
woods will soon become a lot trickier
thousands of years ago before human
civilization took hold the earth had
almost twice as many trees as it does
now most of Europe for example was one
big forest groups all over the world are
working on planting trees and restoring
natural habitats this new data will make
their targets more accurate and it will
certainly change our fundamental
understanding of our planet we now know
we share with 3.04 trillion trees
you